Someone’s going to
hang for this.
Narration:
Foundation is the saga of Hari
Seldon and his followers
Narration:
on their epic quest to save
mankind.
Narration:
Hari is a Mathematician who
predicts a series of crises
Narration:
that will result in the end of
humanity.
Narration:
Brother Day, Brother Dusk and
Brother Dawn, known as The Empire,
Narrartion:
rule the galaxy with an iron
fist.
Our world will live on!
Your worlds will not.
Narration:
The Empire don't know they're
headed for destruction.
Narration:
They feared Hari because he
could forecast the future.
The Empire will fall.
Hari:
Interstellar wars will be
endless.
Hari:
Nothing we do can prevent this.
But we can shorten the dark ages
that follow.
Narration:
Hari enlists a gifted prodigy
named Gaal Dornick
Narration:
to help him build The
Foundation.
Narration:
A stand alone civilization that
will preserve humanity amidst the crisis.
Narration:
For young Gaal, the future now
rests on her shoulders.
The coming generations will have
something to build upon...a
foundation.
Narration:
Hari and his followers are
exiled by The Empire.
Narration:
And sent to distant planet,
Terminus, to build The Foundation.
Gaal:
Terminus, I’ve never even heard
of it.
The seasons are extreme.
Hari:
There’ll be hardships.
Frozen rock, long nights, no
trees for shelter.
Narration:
Against all odds, The
Foundation flourishes.
Narration:
But The Empire now fears it
could soon become obsolete.
Narration:
And tensions between the two
nations become explosive.
Hari:
The war with Empire is
inevitable.
Hari:
Because under the genetic
dynasty there is only one voice!
Narration:
The Empire will stop at nothing
to preserve its very existence.
Narration:
They'll destroy The Foundation
and anyone who supports them.
♪♪
Narration:
We meet Salvor Hardin.
Who are you?
Salvor Hardin...Warden of
Terminus.
Narration:
Her mission is to protect
The Foundation
Narration:
and to preserve Hari Seldon's
plan of prosperity for this
new generation.
Narration:
But The Empire remain intent on
crushing The Foundation.
Seldon!
Gaal Dornick has been
reaching out to me.
Salvor Hardin:
I have to find her.
Narration:
As The Foundation faces imminent
attack,
Narration:
Gaal's messages lead Salvor to
go looking for her.
Narration:
And as the two women finally
meet,
Narration:
the shocking truth becomes
clear.
Narration:
They're from two different
generations.
My name is Salvor Hardin.
I’m your daughter.
Brother Day:
Threaten the peace
and pay a dear price!
♪♪
(Grunts)